Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂运营产生了巨量的碳排放，因此六家最大的公司联合起来，在实现净零排放的道路上大步迈进。投资技术与创新，每桶原油的排放量已平均削减22%，与政府合作创造并保护就业岗位，并正在建设世界最大的碳捕集与储存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在推进，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 查看我们的行动计划。
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At 9 o'clock on the morning of Friday, October 2, 1987, police officers in the small Kentucky town of Central City received a call that they needed to head out to a possible crime scene a few blocks away. An employee of the town's municipal department, located on Legion Drive, had noticed something strange upon arriving at work.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您觉得随时需要帮助，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。1987年10月2日星期五清晨9点，肯塔基州小镇中城（Central City）的警察局接到一个电话，称他们需要前往几个街区外的一个可能存在的犯罪现场。位于军团大道（Legion Drive）上的该镇市政部门的一名员工在上班时注意到了一些异常情况。
Parked haphazardly behind the department's garage was a battered 1977 Pontiac that looked very out of place. The employee had gone up to the seemingly abandoned car to get a closer look. What he discovered led him to contact the police. Lieutenant Billy Fields rushed to the scene and was the first responder to arrive. He immediately recognised the Pontiac. With a population of just 5,000, Central City was small. Degrees of separation between residents were few.
在该部门车库后面，乱七八糟地停着一辆破旧的1977年庞蒂克汽车，显得格格不入。这名员工走到这辆看似被遗弃的汽车旁查看。他的发现促使他联系了警方。比利·菲尔兹中尉（Lieutenant Billy Fields）赶到现场，是第一位到达的响应人员。他一眼就认出了这辆庞蒂克。中城的人口仅有5,000人，是个小镇。居民之间的关系网非常紧密。
The vehicle hadn't been reported stolen nor had anyone filed a missing person's report for its owner. Fields peered through the windows but couldn't see anyone inside. While examining the vehicle's exterior, Fields cited what prompted the municipality employee to summon authorities. Dripping from the locked trunk towards the ground were several strikes of what appeared to be blood. A locksmith was summoned, who was able to unlock the trunk and lift the lid, revealing the grisly scene within. Inside the Pontiac's trunk was the naked body of a woman, wrapped in a blanket and lying in the fetal position.
这辆车既没有被报失窃，也没有人为其车主提交过失踪人口报告。菲尔兹透过车窗向内张望，但看不到里面有任何人。在检查车辆外观时，菲尔兹注意到了促使市政员工报警的原因。从锁着的后备箱向下流到地面的，是几条看起来像是血迹的痕迹。随后人们找来了一名锁匠，他成功打开了后备箱并掀开了盖子，露出了里面毛骨悚然的场景。庞蒂克轿车的后备箱里，躺着一具女性裸尸，被毛毯包裹着，呈胎儿状蜷缩着。
Her body was so badly battered and mutilated that she was unrecognisable. Blood caked her skin and hair in such excess, officers couldn't even determine her race. Eventually, police identified that the victim was the car's owner, 20-year-old Karina Mullen. Karina had been tortured before she died. She'd been stabbed twice, cut in the neck and struck multiple times in the throat, either with a weapon or the culprit's fist. There were so many abrasions that the medical examiner couldn't figure out where one injury ended and another began. There were bruises on her back and arms and one of her nipples had been sliced off.
她的尸体遭到严重殴打和虐待，面目全非。血迹结痂覆盖了她的皮肤和头发，数量之多以至于警官们甚至无法确定她的种族。最终，警方确认死者是该车的车主、20岁的卡琳娜·穆林（Karina Mullen）。卡琳娜在死前曾遭受虐待。她被刺了两次，颈部被割伤，喉咙被钝器或凶手的拳头重击了多次。伤口实在太多，法医甚至无法分清一处伤势在哪里结束、另一处在哪里开始。她的背部和手臂上有瘀伤，其中一个乳头被切掉了。
Defensive wounds on her hands and wrists indicated that she'd put up a fight. Although the examiner didn't detect any semen, it was obvious Karina had endured severe trauma to her genitals. A rape kit was taken. A rape kit was taken. Cause of death was asphyxiation. Whoever had attacked Karina had repeatedly hit her in the head with a blunt instrument which had broken her nose. This in turn blocked her airways and made it impossible for her to breathe. Trace amounts of cannabis and a prescription painkiller were found in Karina's system.
她手部和手腕上的防卫伤表明她曾进行过反抗。虽然法医没有检测到任何精液，但很明显卡琳娜的生殖器受到了严重的创伤。警方提取了强奸证据包。警方提取了强奸证据包。死因是窒息。袭击卡琳娜的人曾用钝器多次击打她的头部，导致她的鼻梁骨折。这反过来阻塞了她的气道，使她无法呼吸。在卡琳娜体内检测到了微量的和大麻以及一种处方止痛药。
But she hadn't been impaired by either drugs or alcohol at the time of her death. Central City was a town that saw its fair share of crime, primarily in the form of illicit drug dealings. But this was a murder of exceptional brutality and it sent shockwaves through the community. The town's small size meant that most of the population had learned of Karina's murder within hours of her body being discovered. Rumors and speculation as to who was responsible ran rife. Tim Williams, a novelist who grew up in the area and was then a teenager who knew Karina, later wrote that he and his acquaintances began to fear a serial killer was on the loose in Central City. But others suspected Karina had been targeted by someone closer to home.
但在她死亡时，她并没有受到毒品或酒精的影响。中城是一个犯罪率不算低的城镇，主要形式是毒品非法交易。但这起谋杀案极其残酷，在整个社区引起了巨大的震动。小镇的规模意味着，在尸体被发现后的几小时内，大部分居民就都知道了卡琳娜遇害的消息。关于谁是凶手的谣言和猜测满天飞。蒂姆·威廉姆斯（Tim Williams）是一位在当地长大的小说家，当时还是一名认识卡琳娜的青少年，他后来写道，他和他的熟人们开始担心有一个连环杀手在中城出没。但其他人则怀疑卡琳娜是被身边更熟悉的人盯上了。
The investigation into Karina Mullins' murder was jointly conducted by the Muhlenberg County Sheriff's Department, with Sheriff Harold McElvane at the home, and the Central City Police Department. Billy Fields led Central City's investigation. This was a personal case for Lieutenant Billy Fields. Like other members of the local law enforcement, he had come to know Karina when she performed clerical work at the station. Karina had incurred a fine and the clerical duties were a form of community service. Investigators worked to piece together Karina's last known movements. Six weeks earlier, Karina had moved into an apartment on the northern end of Central City.
对卡琳娜·穆林谋杀案的调查由穆伦伯格县治安官办公室（Muhlenberg County Sheriff's Department）与中央城警察局（Central City Police Department）联合开展，治安官哈罗德·麦克尔维恩（Harold McElvane）负责坐镇。比利·菲尔兹负责领导中城的调查。对比利·菲尔兹中尉来说，这是一起私人的案件。和当地执法部门的其他成员一样，他是在卡琳娜在警局做文职工作时认识她的。卡琳娜曾被罚款，而这些文职工作是社区服务的一种形式。调查人员努力拼凑卡琳娜生前的最后活动轨迹。六周前，卡琳娜刚搬到中城北端的一间公寓里。
But she'd suddenly decided that she wanted to resume living with her parents, Claude and Patricia Mullin. At the time of her death, she was in the process of moving back home to the more rural area where they lived, ten miles outside of town. Karina was a single mother to a two-year-old girl named Stephanie, who she completely adored. Karina's parents were supportive and helped her care for her daughter. Claude and Patricia told police that they'd last seen Karina the day before her body was found, when she'd dropped Stephanie off at their home so she could enjoy a night out with friends. The plan was for her to return the next morning. Karina resided at the Hillwood Village apartments with her roommate, 21-year-old Angela Smith.
但她突然决定重新和父母克劳德（Claude）和帕特里夏·穆林（Patricia Mullin）一起生活。在她遇害时，她正准备搬回父母位于镇外十英里、更加乡村化的家中。卡琳娜是一个两岁女孩斯蒂芬妮（Stephanie）的单亲妈妈，她对女儿疼爱有加。卡琳娜的父母非常支持她，并帮她照顾女儿。克劳德和帕特里夏告诉警察，他们最后一次见到卡琳娜是在发现她尸体的头一天，当时她把斯蒂芬妮送到他们家，以便自己能和朋友享受一个夜晚的聚会。原本计划是第二天早上回来。卡琳娜与21岁的室友安吉拉·史密斯（Angela Smith）一起住在希尔伍德村（Hillwood Village）公寓。
Like Karina, Angela was a single mother with a toddler and the two women bonded over their shared experiences. Within a few short weeks, they became good friends. Investigators made their way to Hillwood Village to search Karina's apartment. The complex was spread out across six separate two-story brick buildings with green lawns and an outdoor parking lot in the middle. The apartment itself was tiny, with the two women's bedrooms divided by a thin wall. Karina's bedroom became a second crime scene. Officers snapped photographs and took 23 items into evidence. Discarded on the floor by her bed were a pair of men's Leigh brand jeans and a pair of men's underwear.
和卡琳娜一样，安吉拉也是一位带着幼儿的单亲妈妈，两个女人因共同的经历而产生共鸣。在短短几周内，她们成了好朋友。调查人员前往希尔伍德村搜查卡琳娜的公寓。该小区分布在六栋独立的两层砖砌建筑中，中间有绿草坪和室外停车场。公寓本身很小，两个女人的卧室被一面薄墙隔开。卡琳娜的卧室成了第二个犯罪现场。警官们拍了照，并将23件物品作为物证带走。她的床边散落着一条男士李牌（Leigh）牛仔裤和一条男士内裤。
The bed itself was covered in blood, as was the floor. Angela Smith was stunned to learn what had happened to her roommate. She last saw Karina on Thursday the first. With their children in the care of others, Angela and Karina decided to make the most of their night off from parenting and head to a bar in the city of Owensboro, 35 miles north of Central City. The pair took a valium age and after a few drinks returned home at around 11.30. They watched television together for a little while, then Angela went to bed. Shade slept soundly and hadn't heard any unusual noises during the night. But at some point, Karina was attacked, then either left or was taken from the apartment.
床本身沾满血迹，地板也是如此。安吉拉·史密斯得知室友遭遇不幸后震惊不已。她最后一次见到卡琳娜是在10月1日星期四。由于孩子都有人照看，安吉拉和卡琳娜决定充分利用难得的育儿假，前往位于中城以北35英里欧文斯伯勒（Owensboro）市的一家酒吧。两人吃了安定片，喝了几杯后于大约11点30分回到家中。她们一起看了一会儿电视，然后安吉拉就上床睡觉了。她睡得很沉，夜里没有听到任何异常的声音。但在某个时刻，卡琳娜遭到袭击，随后被遗弃或带出了公寓。
Other residents of the Hillwood Village apartments were interviewed. None said they'd heard anything untoward on the night in question, even though the building's ceilings were thin and noise carried easily. However, several Central City locals came forward claiming they'd seen Karina or her car on the night of the murder. One had spotted Karina sitting in her Pontiac outside of a restaurant on South 2nd Street at 11.30pm. Women Dana Morris and Tracy Vincent had been parked in a shopping centre parking lot two hours later when they saw Karina's car drive by. But there was no sign of Karina. The only person inside the vehicle was a man behind the wheel. Investigators asked the women if they could identify the driver.
希尔伍德村公寓的其他居民也接受了采访。没有人说他们在当晚听到任何不寻常的事情，尽管该建筑的天花板很薄，声音很容易传开。然而，几名中城当地人站出来声称，他们在谋杀当晚看到了卡琳娜或她的车。一人在晚上11点30分看到卡琳娜坐在南二街一家餐厅外的庞蒂克车里。两小时后，达娜·莫里斯（Dana Morris）和特雷西·文森特（Tracy Vincent）两名女子将车停在购物中心停车场时，看到卡琳娜的车开过。但没有卡琳娜的踪影。车里唯一的乘客是驾驶座上的一名男子。调查人员询问这两名女子是否能认出司机。
They said that he looked a lot like a local 19-year-old named Jimmy Springer. Karina Mullen had started dating Jimmy Springer six months earlier. Although a year younger than Karina, Springer was six-foot-two and well-built, making him look older than his 19 years. He worked odd jobs, primarily physical ones in construction or maintenance. Karina's family weren't thrilled about the relationship. On multiple occasions, she had called her parents upset because the two had argued. Once, she went over to their house with her face scrubbed bright red. Karina explained that during a fight, Springer had taken a washcloth and vigorously rubbed her face to remove the makeup she was wearing.
她们说，他看起来很像当地一个名叫吉米·斯普林格（Jimmy Springer）的19岁年轻人。卡琳娜·穆林在六个月前开始与吉米·斯普林格约会。虽然比卡琳娜小一岁，但斯普林格身高六英尺二英寸，身材魁梧，这使他看起来比19岁更成熟。他做着零工，主要是建筑或维护方面的体力活。卡琳娜的家人对这段恋情并不满意。她曾多次给父母打电话诉苦，因为两人发生过争吵。有一次，她来到父母家，脸上被擦得通红。卡琳娜解释说，在争吵中，斯普林格拿了一条毛巾用力擦她的脸，以卸掉她化好的妆。
Concerned, Claude Mullen told his daughter to end the relationship and move back home. She agreed. Karina's housemate Angela told police that when she'd gone to bed on the night of October 1, Karina had asked her to leave the front door unlocked in case Springer came by later. Angela agreed with Karina's parents that the relationship was a stormy one and that Springer was a jealous partner. Being Karina's boyfriend, Springer was an obvious suspect. He told investigators that he'd also been out in Owensboro on the night of Thursday October 1, but he hadn't spent time with Karina. Instead, he'd smoked cannabis, then drank at a bar with two friends, Jimmy Jones and Dale Duncan. At around 11pm, they drove back to Dale's house before Springer decided to head over to Karina's apartment.
克劳德·穆林感到担忧，告诉女儿结束这段恋情并搬回家。她同意了。卡琳娜的室友安吉拉告诉警方，当她在10月1日晚上上床睡觉时，卡琳娜曾让她把前门开着，以防斯普林格待会儿过来。安吉拉和卡琳娜的父母一样，认为这段关系充满风波，而且斯普林格是个嫉妒心强的伴侣。作为卡琳娜的男友，斯普林格是一个显而易见的嫌疑人。他告诉调查人员，他也在10月1日星期四晚上去了欧文斯伯勒，但他没有和卡琳娜待在一起。相反，他抽了大麻，然后和两个朋友吉米·琼斯（Jimmy Jones）和戴尔·邓肯（Dale Duncan）在一家酒吧喝酒。大约晚上11点，他们开车回到戴尔家，之后斯普林格决定前往卡琳娜的公寓。
He suspected that she was upset with him for going out with his friends and wanted to check in with her. Springer approached the apartment. The front door was unlocked. He walked in and made his way to Karina's bedroom. The door was closed. Springer turned the handle, but it was locked. He noticed two small smudges of what looked like blood on the door, but thought nothing of it. Assuming Karina must be out, Springer got back in his car and drove around downtown Central City looking for her. After searching unsuccessfully for between 15 and 20 minutes, he gave up. He went back to his friend Dale's house where he stayed overnight. Springer didn't go home until the next morning, when Karina's body was found.
他怀疑她因为自己出去和朋友玩而生他的气，想去看看她。斯普林格走近公寓。前门没有锁。他走了进去，径直来到卡琳娜的卧室。门关着。斯普林格转动把手，但门锁着。他注意到门上有两处看起来像血迹的小污迹，但并没有放在心上。他以为卡琳娜一定出去了，于是又上了车，在市中心中城四处寻找她。在搜寻了15到20分钟无果后，他放弃了。他回到了朋友戴尔的家并在那里过夜。斯普林格直到第二天早上卡琳娜的尸体被发现时才回家。
Investigators weren't buying his story. Springer's tale about finding Karina's bedroom door locked and smeared with blood seemed especially suspicious. Why hadn't he called the police or been more concerned? They theorized that something caused him to become jealous that night. Then, fueled by drugs and alcohol, he killed Karina in a violent rage. When the Mullins learned that Karina's boyfriend was a suspect, they pleaded with Springer and his family not to attend her funeral. When Karina was laid to rest three days after her body was recovered, they stayed away. Almost two weeks after their first conversation with Springer, investigators asked to speak with him again. They hadn't recorded his initial interview or taken any notes, so this time they aimed to obtain a signed statement. While providing his version of events, Springer made a number of remarks that officers deemed suspicious. Their focus on him intensified.
调查人员并不买账他的说法。斯普林格关于发现卡琳娜卧室门反锁并沾有血迹的说法尤其可疑。他为什么不报警或表现得更关心一点？他们推测，当晚有什么事情引起了他的嫉妒。随后，在毒品和酒精的驱使下，他在极度愤怒中杀害了卡琳娜。当穆林一家得知卡琳娜的男友是嫌疑人时，他们恳求斯普林格及其家人不要参加她的葬礼。在卡琳娜尸体被找到三天后安葬时，他们确实没有出席。在与斯普林格进行第一次谈话近两周后，调查人员要求再次与他交谈。他们没有录下他最初的谈话，也没有做任何笔记，所以这次他们的目标是获得一份签了字的供词。在讲述他的事件版本时，斯普林格说了一些警官认为可疑的话。警方对他的怀疑加剧了。
In late October that year, Jimmy Springer was put behind bars. He was held on charges of grand larceny, accused of stealing a $3,000 computer monitor from his workplace. When security guards questioned Springer following the theft, he referenced the murder of Karina Mullen in a highly suspicious manner. The guards then passed this intel onto the police. While sitting in his jail cell in late November, eight weeks after Karina was found in the trunk of her car, Springer was indicted for her murder. Springer pleaded guilty to grand larceny and served a sentence in Nashville. Then, authorities handed him over to Mullenburg County in March 1988. Karina's family were relieved that her killer was behind bars and would have to answer for his crimes. Meanwhile, investigators were steadily building their case.
那年10月下旬，吉米·斯普林格被关进监狱。他因重大盗窃罪被拘留，被指控从工作场所偷窃了一台价值3,000美元的电脑显示器。当保安在盗窃发生后盘问斯普林格时，他以一种非常可疑的方式提到了卡琳娜·穆林的谋杀案。保安随后将这条情报转交给了警方。11月下旬，在卡琳娜被发现在汽车后备箱八周后，斯普林格坐在牢房里被起诉谋杀卡琳娜。斯普林格对重大盗窃罪认罪，并在纳什维尔（Nashville）服刑。随后，当局于1988年3月将他移交给穆伦伯格县。卡琳娜的家人对凶手落网并必须为自己的罪行负责感到宽慰。与此同时，调查人员一直在稳步建立他们的证据链。
Some forensic evidence existed in the form of blood and hair samples taken from Karina's body, but these were assumed to have come from Karina and were never compared to Jimmy Springer. Although a rape kit had been collected, it was never tested. And there wasn't much available in terms of eyewitness reports. No one had seen any blood on Springer around the time of Karina's murder, nor had they seen him with her body. Detectives primarily focused on circumstantial evidence. Springer had a history of drug abuse and criminal behavior. As Karina's boyfriend, he was the most likely suspect. Two people were almost certain they'd seen him driving her car at 1.30 am on the night in question. And his story about leaving her apartment after finding her bedroom door locked smeared with blood sounded too absurd to be true.
有一些法医证据，即从卡琳娜尸体上提取的血样和毛发样本，但这些被认为是卡琳娜本人的，从未与吉米·斯普林格进行比对。虽然提取了强奸证据包，但从未对其进行检测。而且在目击者证词方面也没有太多可用的线索。没有人看到斯普林格在卡琳娜被杀时身上有血，也没有人看到他和她的尸体在一起。侦探们主要关注间接证据。斯普林格有吸毒和犯罪前科。作为卡琳娜的男友，他是最可能的嫌疑人。有两人几乎确信他们在案发当晚凌晨1点30分看到他开着她的车。而他关于发现卡琳娜卧室门锁上并沾满血迹后离开公寓的说法，听起来太荒谬而不真实。
Jimmy Springer's trial began in July 1988. He pleaded not guilty. The prosecution called multiple law enforcement officers to testify, as well as witnesses Dana Morris and Tracy Vincent, who were sure they'd seen Springer behind the wheel of Karina's car. Springer took the stand in his own defense, telling the court that he'd been extremely disturbed by Karina's murder and was in no way responsible. He'd maintained his innocence from the beginning, even though he'd felt pressured to confess during his second interview with police. The interviewing officers had reassured him that they understood why he'd killed Karina, that he'd done it out of love. Springer vehemently denied making certain incriminating remarks which police had attributed to him. When the prosecutor responded by asking if he was alleging a police officer had made a false statement, Springer retorted, I believe he has. He's not the first person that said something false in this case.
吉米·斯普林格的审判于1988年7月开始。他坚决不认罪。检方传唤了多名执法人员出庭作证，还有目击者达娜·莫里斯和特雷西·文森特，她们确信看到斯普林格坐在卡琳娜的车里。斯普林格出庭为自己辩护，告诉法庭他对卡琳娜的谋杀感到极度不安，并且绝对没有责任。他从一开始就坚称自己无罪，尽管他在接受警方第二次讯问时感到了坦白的压力。讯问他的警官向他保证，他们理解他为什么杀害卡琳娜，他是出于爱才这么做的。斯普林格强烈否认自己曾说过警方归咎于他的某些定罪性言论。当检察官质问他是否在指控一名警官作伪证时，斯普林格反驳道：“我相信他说了。他并不是本案中第一个说谎的人。”
Jimmy Springer's friends Dale Duncan and Jimmy Jones also testified, backing up the alibi that he provided for the night of October 1, 1987. He was with them for the entire night, except for a period of 15 to 20 minutes when he went looking for Karina. Dale said Springer returned straight back to his home and stayed overnight. The trial lasted just three days. During his closing address, the prosecutor instructed the jury to ignore how clean-cut Springer looked as he sat in court. Instead, he asked them to pitch a Springer as the violent, drug-fueled individual that he would have been on the night of the murder. In contrast, Springer's attorney argued that the prosecution did not meet their burden of proving Springer was guilty beyond a reasonable doubt, stating, I say to you again that Jim Springer is not guilty of murdering Karina Mullen. It took one hour for the jury to reach a verdict. Jimmy Springer was found not guilty.
吉米·斯普林格的朋友戴尔·邓肯和吉米·琼斯也出庭作证，支持他为1987年10月1日晚间提供的不在场证明。他整晚都和他们在一起，除了出去寻找卡琳娜的15到20分钟时间。戴尔说斯普林格直接回到了他的家并在那里过夜。审判仅持续了三天。在结案陈词中，检察官指示陪审团忽略斯普林格在法庭上显得多么干净利落的外表。相反，他要求他们把斯普林格想象成他在谋杀当晚那样一个暴力、受毒品驱使的人。相比之下，斯普林格的律师辩称，控方未能达到毫无合理怀疑地证明斯普林格有罪的举证责任，并表示：“我再次对你们说，吉姆·斯普林格没有谋杀卡琳娜·穆林。”陪审团花了一个小时就达成了裁决。吉米·斯普林格被判无罪。
Karina's family was devastated. Following the trial, Mullenburg County authorities declared the case effectively closed. Unless evidence emerged implicating another person in the crime, they would not be investigating it. As far as they were concerned, the person responsible had been tried and got away with it. In December 1988, police returned Karina's 1977 Pontiac to her parents. Upon receiving the car, Claude and Patricia Mullen decided to look inside. A number of innocuous items were scattered around the vehicle. Then, they checked under the driver's seat. Wedged beneath the seat was a knife, caked in dried blood and human hairs. Discovering the weapon used against their daughter was not only traumatising, it affirmed Claude and Patricia's growing belief that detectives had botched the investigation into her murder. The Central City Police Chief defended the oversight, noting, It's possible that the knife could have been overlooked. With it being lodged down in the seat, it's possible that we could have missed that.
卡琳娜的家人悲痛欲绝。审判结束后，穆伦伯格县当局宣布该案实际上已经结案。除非出现涉及其他人的犯罪证据，否则他们不会再进行调查。在他们看来，真正的凶手已经受审并逍遥法外了。1988年12月，警方将卡琳娜那辆1977年的庞蒂克轿车归还给她的父母。拿到车后，克劳德和帕特里夏·穆林决定往里面看看。车里散落着许多无害的物品。然后，他们检查了驾驶座下方。卡在座椅下方的是一把沾满干涸血迹和人类毛发的刀。发现杀害女儿的凶器不仅令人痛苦，也证实了克劳德和帕特里夏日益坚定的信念，即侦探们搞砸了这起谋杀案的调查。中城市警察局局长为这一疏忽辩护道：“这把刀很有可能是被忽略了。因为它卡在座椅深处，我们有可能漏掉了这一点。”
The knife was sent to state authorities for testing. Entirely dubious of the Central City Police Department's ability to do their job, the Mullen's requested that the case also be transferred to Kentucky State Police. Their request was granted. Neither the discovery of the bloodstained knife nor the transfer of the case led to the breakthrough that the Mullen's were hoping for. By the beginning of 1989, they were still awaiting lab results. Eventually, they found out that nothing significant was uncovered from the knife. They continued to petition for Carina's case to be solved, while also raising her now four-year-old daughter, Stephanie. Claude Mullen told Kentucky newspaper The Messenger Inquirer, It's so hard. Truthfully, we're not doing too good. We're just trying to make it day to day. Patricia Mullen spoke of the family's ongoing grief, stating,
这把刀被送到州当局进行检测。穆林夫妇对中城市警察局的工作能力完全不信任，要求将案件移交给肯塔基州警察局。他们的请求得到了批准。无论是发现血迹斑斑的刀还是案件的移交，都没有带来穆林夫妇所希望的突破。到1989年初，他们仍在等待实验室的结果。最终，他们发现这把刀没有查出什么重大线索。他们继续呼吁解决卡琳娜的案件，同时抚养她现在四岁的女儿斯蒂芬妮。克劳德·穆林告诉肯塔基州报纸《信使快报》（The Messenger Inquirer）：“这太难了。说实话，我们过得并不好。我们只是在勉强过日子。”帕特里夏·穆林谈到家庭持续的悲痛时说：
As far as missing her, I can't put it into words how much we do. I just don't have any answers. I don't understand how someone can die like that, and still no one has been held responsible for it. Meanwhile, Jimmy Springer had moved on with his life. He stayed in Central City, but no one really bothered him about the murder. Occasionally, he saw the case's lead investigator, Lieutenant Billy Fields, around town, and the officer would wave at him. Springer just ignored him. He began working for a local courier service and got married. In an interview with The Messenger Inquirer, Springer stated, It's hard, yes, but I have to go on. I still have nightmares. I still think of the way she died, but I try to push it out of my mind. I ask myself why it was so brutal. I hate to think about what she went through. As bad as it is for us, we know it's worse for her parents.
“至于对她的思念，我无法用言语来表达我们有多想她。我只是找不到任何答案。我不明白怎么会有人这样死去，却仍然没有人为此承担责任。”与此同时，吉米·斯普林格的生活翻开了新的一页。他留在了中城，但没有人真的因为谋杀案去烦他。偶尔，他会在镇上看到该案的主谋调查员比利·菲尔兹中尉，而这位警官会向他挥手致意。斯普林格直接无视了他。他开始为当地一家快递服务公司工作并结了婚。在接受《信使快报》采访时，斯普林格表示：“这很难，是的，但我必须继续生活。我仍然会做噩梦。我仍然会想起她死时的样子，但我尽量把它赶出脑海。我问自己为什么会这么残忍。我一想到她经历的一切就很难受。不管对我们有多糟糕，我们知道对她的父母来说更糟。”
The second anniversary of Carina's death came and went. Then, in January 1990, an election was held in Muhlenberg County for the position of sheriff. The incumbent was Harold McElvane, who had helped lead the investigation into Carina's murder. Running against him was Wayne Moore, who ran on the platform that he would reopen the notorious unsolved case if he won. Moore was publicly critical of the way both agencies had coordinated their investigation, saying, If it had been handled properly in the first place, this thing would have been closed and there would have been a conviction by now. Wayne Moore defeated Sheriff McElvane. True to his word, he reopened the Carina Muhlen case and appointed one of his deputies, Terry Arnett, to lead the investigation.
卡琳娜逝世两周年的纪念日来了又去。接着，在1990年1月，穆伦伯格县举行了治安官职位的选举。现任治安官是哈罗德·麦克尔维恩，他曾协助领导卡琳娜谋杀案的调查。与他竞选的是韦恩·穆尔（Wayne Moore），他的竞选纲领是如果当选，将重新调查这起臭名昭著的未决案件。穆尔公开批评两个机构协调调查的方式，他说：“如果一开始处理得当，这件事早就了结了，现在就已经定罪了。”韦恩·穆尔击败了麦克尔维恩治安官。践行承诺，他重新调查了卡琳娜·穆林案，并任命他的副手特里·阿内特（Terry Arnett）领导调查。
Moore and Arnett reached out to the Central City Police Department to request access to their evidence. They admitted that everything they had relating to the case had somehow been lost during the past two years. Frustrated, Moore issued public appeals for anyone with information about Carina's murder to come forward. One day, the phone rang at the Muhlenberg County Sheriff's Office. Moore answered. An unidentified male caller demanded to know why he was meddling in the Carina Muhlen case. Moore explained that he wanted it solved. The anonymous caller threatened, Take my advice and stay out of it or you'll find your ass in the Green River, referring to a tributary that passed right by town. Moore retorted, I can swim, then hung up the phone.
穆尔和阿内特联系了中城市警察局，要求查阅他们的证据。他们承认，他们掌握的与此案有关的一切在过去两年里不知何故都丢失了。穆尔感到沮丧，公开呼吁任何掌握卡琳娜谋杀案信息的人站出来。一天，穆伦伯格县治安官办公室的电话响了。穆尔接了电话。一个身份不明的男性来电者质问他为什么要插手卡琳娜·穆林案。穆尔解释说他想把案子破了。匿名来电者威胁道：“听我一句劝，少管闲事，否则你会发现自己屁股朝下躺在绿河（Green River）里，”指的是穿城而过的一条支流。穆尔反驳道：“我会游泳，”然后挂断了电话。
Over the next few days, Moore calls followed. During one, the caller warned Moore to, Leave things alone or somebody is fixing to tear your ass up. In another, a menacing voice asked him to consider how much he cared about his wife and children. Moore was undeterred. Precautions were put in place to protect his family, but he remained determined to see the case solved. He was convinced that the threatening calls meant the killer or killers were rattled by his digging. Moore issued a public statement via the messenger inquirer stating, Hell or high water won't stop me. People are starting to sweat. I think some people are really getting scared. We've got some good leads, but that's all they are right now. It's circumstantial stuff. But we're in too deep to back out now.
在接下来的几天里，穆尔陆续接到威胁电话。其中一个电话里，来电者警告穆尔：“少管闲事，否则有人要收拾你了。”在另一个电话里，一个威胁的声音让他考虑一下他有多在乎自己的妻子和孩子。穆尔没有被吓退。采取了保护家人的预防措施后，他依然决心将此案查个水落石出。他确信这些威胁电话意味着凶手或凶手们被他的深入调查惊动了。穆尔通过《信使快报》发表了一份公开声明，称：“刀山火海也阻止不了我。人们开始冒汗了。我想有些人真的开始害怕了。我们有一些不错的线索，但目前也仅此而已。都是些间接证据。但我们陷得太深，现在已经无法退缩了。”
Requiring further assistance, Moore requested help from the Federal Bureau of Investigation in 1992. Their cutting edge technology was far superior to anything possessed by the Muhlenberg County Sheriff's Department. Using sophisticated lasers, FBI agents spent 10 hours meticulously examining Corina's car. They were able to identify some bloody prints on the boot's exterior that had gone undetected by earlier investigators. Moore was excited. Only the killer could have left bloodied handprints in that spot. If he was able to find a matching print, either already in the database or sometime down the track, he'd be well on his way to making an arrest. Moore and Deputy Arnett shared the good news with the Mullens while cautioning them that they still had a long way to go. But Claude was thrilled. For the first time in four years, he finally had something to feel positive about.
由于需要进一步协助，穆尔于1992年向联邦调查局（FBI）寻求帮助。他们尖端的技术远优于穆伦伯格县治安官办公室所拥有的任何技术。利用高精尖的激光，联邦调查局特工花了10个小时仔细检查了卡琳娜的车。他们能够识别出靴子外部的一些血手印，这些手印之前被调查人员忽略了。穆尔很兴奋。只有凶手才会在那个地方留下带血的手印。如果他能找到匹配的指印（无论是在数据库中还是在未来的某个时候），他距离实施逮捕就指日可待了。穆尔和副手阿内特将这个好消息分享给穆林夫妇，同时也提醒他们前方还有很长的路要走。但克劳德欣喜若狂。四年里头一次，他终于有了一件可以感到积极的事情。
The Mullens' hope dissipated when the investigation slowed again. From the outside, it appeared as though nothing was happening. Months then years passed until two decades had gone by since Corina's murder. For that entire time, a woman was holding onto a secret that could break the case wide open. All she needed to do was speak up. 16-year-old Sarah, not her real name, walked alone down the Central City streets leading towards her home. It was night time on Thursday, October 1, 1987, and Sarah had spent the evening at a friend's house. Central City had its murky underworld and ongoing drug-related crimes, but it was still a small town where teenagers felt safe being out alone after dark. Sarah just reached her family's home when a police cruiser pulled up. Two men got out of the vehicle and walked straight up to her. They suddenly grabbed her and dragged her into the back seat of the car.
随着调查再次陷入停滞，穆林夫妇的希望破灭了。从表面上看，似乎什么也没有发生。几个月接着几年过去了，直到卡琳娜遇害二十年过去。在这整段时间里，有一个女人一直保守着一个能够彻底打破僵局的秘密。她需要做的只是说出来。16岁的莎拉（化名）独自走在中城通往她家的街道上。那是1987年10月1日星期四的夜晚，莎拉在朋友家度过了整个晚上。中城有其阴暗的地下世界和持续不断的涉毒犯罪，但它仍然是一个小镇，青少年在天黑后独自在外感到安全。莎拉刚走到家人住所时，一辆警车停了下来。两个男人从车里下来，径直朝她走去。他们突然抓住她，把她拖进了车的后座。
Sarah was terrified. One of the men was huge. He looked to be in his early twenties and was six foot five inches tall with a heavy set build and a round, pudgy face. Sarah had never seen him before, but she recognized her other abductor. Very well known around town, he was an imposing man standing six foot three and weighing 265 pounds. It was 44-year-old Central City police lieutenant Billy Fields. The two men drove Sarah a short distance, then parked the car. As she was forced outside, she saw they were at the Hillwood Village Apartments Complex. She was marched up to one of the residences. It was the apartment Corina Mullen shared with her flatmate Angela Smith, both of whom were home. Several other men were also present, including Corina's boyfriend to Jimmy Springer, a short 18-year-old Sarah new named Jimmy Cramer, and another individual whom she didn't know. The group seemed to be just sitting around and drinking after a night out. All of a sudden, Fields began picking a fight with Corina. Sarah couldn't understand what was going on, but it sounded as though they were arguing about Corina being pregnant.
莎拉吓坏了。其中一个男人块头极大。他看起来二十出头，身高六英尺五英寸（约1.96米），身材魁梧，有着一张圆圆胖胖的脸。莎拉以前从未见过他，但她认出了另一个绑架者。他在镇上非常出名，是一个身材魁梧的男人，身高六英尺三英寸（约1.91米），体重265磅（约120公斤）。他就是44岁的中城市警察局中尉比利·菲尔兹。这两个男人开车把莎拉载了一小段路，然后把车停下。当她被强行带下车时，她看到他们是在希尔伍德村公寓大楼。她被押送到其中一个住宅。那是卡琳娜·穆林与室友安吉拉·史密斯合租的公寓，两人当时都在家。现场还有其他几个人，包括卡琳娜的男友吉米·斯普林格、一个莎拉认识的名叫吉米·克莱默（Jimmy Cramer）的18岁矮个子男生，以及另一个她不认识的人。这群人似乎只是在夜出之后围坐在一起喝酒。突然间，菲尔兹开始找卡琳娜的麻烦。莎拉听不懂发生了什么，但听起来他们好像在争论卡琳娜怀孕的事。
Fields suddenly grabbed Corina and pulled her into her bedroom. The large man who had helped abduct Sarah got up and pushed Sarah into the room behind them. They were also followed by Jimmy Springer and Jimmy Cramer. Sarah heard Fields snarl at Corina that she was going to get what she deserved. He viciously beat Corina with a metal bar before throwing her on the bed and raping her in front of everyone. He punched her repeatedly while telling her to keep her mouth shut. Cramer and the other abductor joined in on the beating and threats, then also raped Corina. Corina's boyfriend Jimmy Springer didn't seem to be a willing participant. He never hit Corina and at times tried to help her, but was stopped by the other men.
菲尔兹突然抓住卡琳娜，把她拉进她的卧室。那个帮着绑架莎拉的高大男人站起身，把莎拉推进了他们身后的房间。吉米·斯普林格和吉米·克莱默也随之跟了进去。莎拉听到菲尔兹对卡琳娜咆哮说她会得到应有的下场。他用一根金属棒残忍地殴打卡琳娜，然后把她扔到床上，当着所有人的面强奸了她。他一边殴打她一边让她闭嘴。克莱默和另一个绑架者也加入了殴打和威胁的行列，随后也强奸了卡琳娜。卡琳娜的男友吉米·斯普林格似乎不是出于自愿。他从未打过卡琳娜，有时还试图帮助她，但被其他男人阻止了。
The three of them eventually insisted that Springer rape Corina as well. Throughout the vicious attack, Corina's housemate Angela sobbed hysterically from the next room, but didn't intervene. Sarah watched on in terror. She couldn't help Corina because she was being forcefully held down by one of the men. Fields eventually turned his attention to Sarah, pushing her on the bed on top of Corina and sexually assaulting her. Then Fields raped Corina again while using a knife to stab and cut her. Corina had initially screamed and tried to fight back, but Fields choked her until she could no longer make a sound. Naked and soaked in blood, Corina was unrecognizable. Sarah couldn't tell if she was dead or just unconscious. Fields and his main accomplice picked up Corina's body and placed her in the boot of her own car.
他们三人最终坚持要求斯普林格也强奸卡琳娜。在整场残酷的袭击中，卡琳娜的室友安吉拉在隔壁房间歇斯底里地抽泣，但没有进行干预。莎拉惊恐地看着这一切。她无法帮助卡琳娜，因为她自己被其中一个男人强行按倒在地。菲尔兹最终将注意力转向莎拉，把她推到卡琳娜身上的床上并对其实施性侵。接着菲尔兹再次强奸了卡琳娜，同时用刀刺伤并割伤了她。卡琳娜最初尖叫并试图反击，但菲尔兹掐住她的脖子，直到她发不出声音。赤身裸体、血迹斑斑的卡琳娜面目全非。莎拉分不清她是死了还是只是失去了知觉。菲尔兹和他的主要同伙抬起卡琳娜的尸体，把她放进她自己的车后备箱里。
Fields then climbed into the passenger seat and ordered Sarah to drive the Pontiac to a garage used by a municipal department downtown. Sarah did as she was told. Fields provided directions as she drove, interspersed with threats as to what would happen to her if she ever told anyone what she'd seen. Dawn was breaking as Sarah pulled up at the garage on Legion Drive. The other man who had abducted her earlier in the night headed to the garage in his own car and was already there waiting for them. Sarah put the Pontiac into park and got out. While the two men headed to the boot where Corina's body lay, Sarah spotted her opportunity to escape. She raced as quickly as she could in the direction of her home.
随后，菲尔兹坐上副驾驶座，命令莎拉把这辆庞蒂克开到市中心一个市政部门使用的车库。莎拉照做了。菲尔兹在驾驶途中指明方向，并夹杂着威胁，警告她如果敢把所见所闻告诉任何人会有什么下场。当莎拉将车开到军团大道的车库时，天蒙蒙亮了。早些时候绑架她的另一个男人开着自己的车前往车库，已经在那里等候他们了。莎拉把庞蒂克挂上P档并下了车。当两个男人走向放着卡琳娜尸体的后备箱时，莎拉发现了逃跑的机会。她以最快的速度朝自己家的方向跑去。
The following morning, a call came through to Central City Police regarding the discovery of Corina Mullen's car. Billy Fields responded to the call and was the first to arrive at the scene. He was later placed in charge of the investigation into Corina's murder. Sarah confided in her mother but didn't tell anyone else what had happened. They stayed silent about the matter from then on, terrified of the repercussions if they spoke out against the well-known local police officer. Even when Sarah's sister later started dating Jimmy Cramer and her father began working alongside him, Sarah kept her secret. In the years that followed, Sarah worked with Kentucky State Police as an informant in several drugs cases. Billy Fields called Sarah from time to time, muttering threats down the phone and warning her against speaking out.
第二天早上，中城警察局接到关于发现卡琳娜·穆林汽车的电话。比利·菲尔兹接了电话，并第一个赶到现场。他后来被指派负责卡琳娜谋杀案的调查。莎拉向母亲吐露了实情，但没有把发生的事情告诉其他人。从那时起，他们对此事保持沉默，害怕如果对这个知名的当地警官公开直言会遭到报复。甚至当莎拉的妹妹后来开始和吉米·克莱默约会、她的父亲开始与他共事时，莎拉也守口如瓶。在接下来的几年里，莎拉作为肯塔基州警察局的线人参与了多起毒品案件。比利·菲尔兹时不时会给莎拉打电话，在电话里嘟囔着威胁并警告她不要说出去。
She never said a word to anyone until mid-2006. Sarah, who was now 35 years old, was talking with Kentucky State Police Detective Steve Silphies about an unrelated crime. It was during this conversation when she finally confessed that she had witnessed the murder of Corina Mullen. Silphies gave her details to a colleague named Detective Damon Fleming, who'd recently been assigned the almost 20-year-old cold case. Fleming inherited a wealth of information regarding Corina's murder from Mullenburg County Sheriff's Deputy Terry Arnett, who doggedly pursued the case for years. Arnett had been getting close to the truth and was certain he knew who the killers were. He felt so confident that they would one day have enough to make an arrest that he reassured Claude Mullen on multiple occasions. Don't give up, we know who did it.
直到2006年中期，她才对任何人吐露只字片语。当时35岁的莎拉正在与肯塔基州警察局侦探史蒂夫·西尔菲斯（Steve Silphies）谈论一起无关的犯罪。正是在这次谈话中，她终于承认自己目睹了卡琳娜·穆林的谋杀案。西尔菲斯将她的细节提供给了一位名叫达蒙·弗莱明（Damon Fleming）的侦探同事，后者最近刚被指派负责这起将近20年的积案。弗莱明从穆伦伯格县治安官副手特里·阿内特那里继承了大量关于卡琳娜谋杀案的信息，阿内特多年来一直锲而不舍地追查此案。阿内特当时已经接近真相，并且确信自己知道凶手是谁。他深信总有一天能掌握足够的证据实施逮捕，因此多次安慰克劳德·穆林：“不要放弃，我们知道是谁干的。”
Then, in 2004, Arnett was diagnosed with cancer. He died the following year without having solved Corina's murder, but his case file contained many leads. Detective Fleming met with Sarah and interviewed her at length. He found her very credible. Her allegations against Lieutenant Billy Fields didn't come as a total shock to those who knew him. Billy Fields was renowned in Central City for being involved in, and seemingly leading, a drug ring. Rumours that he was involved in the Mullen case had been whispered throughout the town for years. In 1992, when the FBI became involved in the case, Fields abruptly retired from the Central City Police Department at the age of 49. This only fueled local gossip about the case, though all he would say was,
然后，在2004年，阿内特被诊断出癌症。他在第二年带着未破的卡琳娜谋杀案遗憾离世，但他的案卷中包含许多线索。弗莱明侦探会见了莎拉并对她进行了详细的采访。他发现她非常可信。她对比利·菲尔兹中尉的指控对于那些了解他的人来说并不完全是个震惊的消息。比利·菲尔兹在中城因参与并似乎领导了一个贩毒团伙而闻名。关于他卷入穆林案的谣言在整个小镇流传了多年。1992年，当联邦调查局介入此案时，菲尔兹在49岁时突然从中央城警察局退休。这只会火上浇油地加剧当地对案件的八卦流言，尽管他唯一会说的是：
I knew the girl, I knew who she was, but that was the extent of it. There were two individuals Sarah had seen assist Fields that she couldn't name. One played a smaller role and was already at Corina's apartment when Fields and his accomplice took her there. Fleming had a theory about who this might be. Going through the case file that Arnett had put together, Fleming discovered a recorded police interview with a local man named Crandall Gibson. Apparently discussing Corina's murder, Gibson had told the officers, you can't get me without the other two. Fleming wondered whether Gibson was one of the people at Corina's apartment that night. As the recording wasn't authenticated and had been made prior to Fleming being assigned the case, he couldn't use it as evidence.
“我认识那个女孩，我知道她是谁，但也就仅此而已。”莎拉见过两个协助菲尔兹但她叫不出名字的人。其中一人扮演的角色较小，当菲尔兹和他的同伙把卡琳娜带到公寓时，他已经在那儿了。弗莱明对这可能是谁有一个推测。在翻阅阿内特整理的案卷时，弗莱明发现了一份录下的警方与当地人克兰德尔·吉布森（Crandall Gibson）的谈话记录。吉布森显然在谈论卡琳娜的谋杀案时告诉警察：“没有另外两个人，你们抓不到我。”弗莱明想知道吉布森是否是当晚在卡琳娜公寓里的其中一人。由于该录音未经证实，且是在弗莱明接手此案之前录制的，他无法将其用作证据。
Both Arnett and Gibson had since passed away and couldn't be questioned about it. The second unknown man had played a much larger role in helping Fields abduct Sarah, assault Corina and dispose of her body. Sarah didn't recall hearing his name, but his face and imposing physical presence were still crystal clear in her mind. Detective Fleming showed her a mugshot of a man who was a known accomplice of Fields. Now 43 years old, he had the same round, pudgy face, but framed by a full head of grey hair and a wiry goatee. Sarah recognized him right away as one of the main perpetrators. His name was Jeffrey Boyd. Boyd was already incarcerated at the Kentucky State Penitentiary for a variety of crimes, ranging from drug trafficking to tampering with evidence. One of the other alleged attackers, Jimmy Cramer, had two prior convictions, one for sexual assault in 1984 and another for rape in 1988, but was now freely living his life, as was Billy Fields.
阿内特和吉布森此后都已去世，无法再就此接受讯问。第二个身份不明的男人在协助菲尔兹绑架莎拉、侵犯卡琳娜并处理她的尸体方面扮演了更重要的角色。莎拉不记得听到过他的名字，但他的脸和魁梧的身材在她脑海中仍然清晰可见。弗莱明侦探给她看了一名男子的mugshot（面部照片），此人是菲尔兹众所周知的同伙。现年43岁的他有着同样圆圆胖胖的脸，但周围环绕着一头灰发和一撮细长的小山羊胡。莎拉一眼就认出他就是主要行凶者之一。他的名字叫杰弗里·“杰夫”·博伊德（Jeffrey Boyd）。博伊德因从贩毒到篡改证据等一系列罪行，当时已被关押在肯塔基州立监狱。另一名被指控的袭击者吉米·克莱默有两次前科，一次是1984年的性侵犯，另一次是1988年的强奸，但现在和比利·菲尔兹一样，过着自由的生活。
It turned out that some central city residents had known Fields had a connection with Corina Mullen for years. Although Corina had been dating Jimmy Springer, she was also romantically involved with Fields. Edna McGee-Eves lived in the same apartment complex as Corina. Occasionally, the two women chatted when they crossed paths. Edna noticed Fields police crews are parked directly outside Corina's apartment on several occasions and was under the impression that they were dating. She had also seen Jeffrey Boyd and Jimmy Cramer at the apartment before. At least two other witnesses came forward to say they saw Fields and Corina together on multiple occasions, including the site manager for the Hillwood apartments. One day, Fields approached him to request that he keep Corina as a tenant, even though it was her housemate Angela Smith who was on the lease. Very quickly though, things seemed to sour between Fields and Corina.
原来，一些中心城区的居民多年来一直知道菲尔兹与科里纳·马伦有染。尽管科里纳一直在和吉米·斯普林格约会，但她也与菲尔兹有浪漫纠葛。埃德娜·麦基-埃夫斯和科里纳住在同一个公寓大楼里。偶尔，这两个女人在偶遇时会聊天。埃德娜注意到菲尔兹的警车曾数次停在科里纳的公寓正外侧，并以为他们在交往。她以前也曾在公寓里见过杰弗里·博伊德和吉米·克莱默。至少还有另外两名目击者站出来说，他们多次看到菲尔兹和科里纳在一起，其中包括希尔伍德公寓的现场经理。有一天，菲尔兹找到他，请求他让科里纳继续租房，尽管租约上写的是她的室友安吉拉·史密斯。不过，很快情况似乎就变坏了，菲尔兹和科里纳之间产生了隔阂。
Edna McGee-Eves noticed that Corina had started to look increasingly upset. One day, she stopped to chat with Corina, who confessed that she thought she might be pregnant. She'd told Fields that he was the father. He wasn't happy about it. On the night of Corina's murder, Edna noticed Corina's car backed right up to the curb with its boot open. Scanning her eyes around the parking lot, Edna realized Fields police crews are was there as well. When news broke of Corina's murder the following day, Edna realized she might have seen something significant. Too scared to come forward, given Fields himself was leading the investigation, she kept the knowledge to herself for years to come. Later stating,
埃德娜·麦基-埃夫斯注意到科里纳开始显得越来越沮丧。有一天，她停下来和科里纳聊天，科里纳坦白说她觉得自己可能怀孕了。她告诉菲尔兹他是孩子父亲。他对此并不高兴。在科里纳被谋杀的当晚，埃德娜注意到科里纳的车倒车停在路边，后备箱开着。埃德娜扫视了停车场，发现菲尔兹的警车也在那里。第二天科里纳被谋杀的消息传出后，埃德娜意识到她可能看到了重要的事情。由于菲尔兹本人正在领导调查，她太害怕而不敢站出来，因此把这个秘密藏在心里多年。后来她表示：
My concern was, who do I talk to? Who do I go to? What do I do? Fields had never disclosed just how close he was to Corina. During the original investigation, it was his job to doorknock all of her neighbors and take statements from everyone in the building. Investigators theorized that he might have threatened them into keeping quiet about anything they might have seen or heard. Digging through official police documentation, detectives discovered a receipt from August 8, 1988. It showed that Fields signed out 18 items of evidence from the Kentucky State Police Lab that related to Corina's murder, including her rape kit. None of the evidence had ever been examined because Central City Police hadn't requested testing, despite the fact that Jimmy Springer had already been tried. Moreover, Fields asked that the items be returned to him untested.
我的担忧是，我跟谁谈？我去找谁？我该怎么做？菲尔兹从未透露过他与科里纳的关系有多亲密。在最初的调查中，他的工作是走访她的所有邻居并获取大楼里每个人的证词。调查人员推测，他可能威胁过他们，让他们对看到或听到的任何事情保持沉默。通过翻阅官方警察档案，侦探们发现了一张1988年8月8日的收据。它显示菲尔兹从肯塔基州警察实验室签领了18件与科里纳谋杀案有关的证据，其中包括她的强奸检测包。这些证据从未被检验过，因为中心城区警察局没有要求进行测试，尽管吉米·斯普林格已经受审。此外，菲尔兹要求将这些未经测试的物品退还给他。
Asking for evidence that had not been examined by forensic technicians was highly unusual behavior from an investigator. The receipt was the final record in the chain of custody. Detectives weren't sure where the evidence ended up after being signed out to Fields, but they suspected he destroyed it. Despite multiple witnesses telling police Corina believed she was pregnant at the time of her death, nothing in her autopsy indicated this was the case. Investigators wondered if she merely suspected she was pregnant and never confirmed it. Whether Fields believed she was carrying his child or not, another motive soon emerged. While Corina was completing her community service by doing clerical work at Central City Police Station, she became friendly with an officer there named John Scott. The pair already knew each other through Scott's sisters, but working in close proximity brought them even closer together.
索要未经法医技术人员检验的证据对于调查人员来说是非常罕见的举动。这张收据是保管链中的最后记录。侦探们不确定证据在签给菲尔兹后最终流向何处，但他们怀疑他将其销毁了。尽管多名目击者告诉警方，科里纳在死时认为自己怀孕了，但她的尸检报告中没有任何迹象表明这一点。调查人员怀疑她只是怀疑自己怀孕了，但从未得到证实。无论菲尔兹是否相信她怀着他的孩子，另一个动机很快浮出水面。当科里纳在中心城区警察局做文职工作以完成社区服务时，她与那里的一名名叫约翰·斯科特的警察成为了朋友。两人通过斯科特的姐姐们已经认识，但近距离的工作让他们更加亲密。
Eventually, Corina felt comfortable enough to confide in Scott. Two days before her death, she told him that her boyfriend Jimmy Springer was involved in a drug ring and was also trafficking stolen property interstate. He was undertaking these criminal activities alongside Jeffrey Boyd and his longtime friend Dale Duncan. Corina agreed to file an official report about these allegations, which Scott recorded for her. After receiving the report, Officer Scott told his colleague Lieutenant Billy Fields about it. What neither Scott nor Corina knew was that Fields was commonly understood to be the mastermind behind the drug and theft ring. Detectives believed that he murdered Corina out of revenge and to keep her from speaking further about the matter. Investigators tracked down more witnesses with incriminating stories to tell.
最终，科里纳感到足够自在，向斯科特吐露了心声。在她死前两天，她告诉他，她的男友吉米·斯普林格卷入了一个贩毒集团，并且还在跨州贩运赃物。他与杰弗里·博伊德以及他的老朋友戴尔·邓肯一起从事这些犯罪活动。科里纳同意就这些指控提交一份正式报告，斯科特为她作了记录。收到报告后，斯科特警官将此事告诉了他的同事比利·菲尔兹中尉。斯科特和科里纳都不知道的是，菲尔兹普遍被认为是毒品和盗窃集团的幕后主使。侦探们认为他谋杀科里纳是为了报复，并阻止她进一步谈论此事。调查人员追踪到了更多有罪证故事的目击者。
A local man named Jimmy Gunn saw Jeffrey Boyd approach Corina at a diner the day before she was killed. Boyd threatened Corina with a gun and stated, bitch, you'll die tonight. Jimmy immediately phoned the police station. Billy Fields took his call and said he'd attend to the matter. As the police station was just a couple of hundred yards from the diner, Jimmy expected the officer would arrive quickly. But minutes passed and there was no sign of him. Meanwhile, Boyd moved his car and then his mother turned up at the restaurant. Jimmy saw Boyd pass something over to her, which Jimmy believed to be his firearm.
当地一名叫吉米·冈恩的男子看到杰弗里·博伊德在她被杀前一天在一家餐馆接近科里纳。博伊德用枪威胁科里纳并说：“贱人，你今晚就得死。”吉米立即打电话给警察局。比利·菲尔兹接了电话，说他会处理此事。由于警察局距离餐馆只有几百码远，吉米期望警察会迅速赶到。但几分钟过去了，没有他的踪影。与此同时，博伊德移开了他的车，随后他的母亲出现在餐馆里。吉米看到博伊德把什么东西交给了她，吉米认为那是他的枪支。
When Fields finally arrived at the scene almost 20 minutes later, Boyd held up his hands as though to prove that he was unarmed. Another witness came forward to say he saw Fields and Boyd in the early hours of October 2, 1987. The pair were walking along Legion Drive, the same street near where Corina Mullins car was dumped with her corpse inside. Mike Phillips, who had been a central city police officer back in 1987, also reportedly saw Boyd walking near Legion Drive at 3am that same day, 6 hours before Corina's body was found. Armed with this new evidence, Detective Damon Fleming of Kentucky State Police began making arrests on November 2, 2006. Retired central city police officer Billy Fields, now 63 years old, was charged with first-degree rape, kidnapping, murder, and tampering with evidence. He was also charged with one count of sodomy for his assault of eyewitness Sarah. His accomplice Jimmy Cramer, aged 37, was also arrested and charged with first-degree rape, kidnapping, and murder.
当菲尔兹在近20分钟后终于到达现场时，博伊德举起双手，仿佛在证明自己没有武器。另一名目击者站出来说，他在1987年10月2日凌晨看到菲尔兹和博伊德。两人正沿着军团大道行走，这条街正是科里纳·穆林斯的车被抛弃且尸体在车内的地方。据报道，1987年担任中心城区警察的迈克·菲利普斯当天清晨3点也看到博伊德在军团大道附近行走，当时距离科里纳的尸体被发现还有6个小时。带着这些新证据，肯塔基州警察局的侦探达蒙·弗莱明于2006年11月2日开始实施逮捕。63岁的退休中心城区警官比利·菲尔兹被控一级强奸、绑架、谋杀和篡改证据。他还因袭击目击证人莎拉而被控一项鸡奸罪。他的同伙、37岁的吉米·克莱默也被捕，并被控一级强奸、绑架和谋杀。
He spoke out against the arrest, telling reporters, That's one thing I'm not. I ain't no murderer, rapist, or kidnapper. No way. I would take a DNA test, a lie detector test, whatever, to prove my innocence. I hope they do get whoever did this because they do need to be put away, but I know I didn't have anything to do with it and don't know nothing about it. The third individual arrested was 40-year-old Angela Smith, Corina's former housemate. Because she had been present during the rape and murder of Corina, yet never tried to intervene, she was charged with complicity to rape, kidnapping, and murder. Jeffrey Boyd was already serving time for drug trafficking and evidence tampering. He was charged the following day with rape, kidnapping, and murder. As Jimmy Springer had already been tried and acquitted of Corina's murder in 1988, he couldn't be charged with killing her again. Instead, he was charged with complicity to rape, kidnapping, and sodomy.
他公开反对逮捕，对记者说：“我绝对不是那种人。我不是什么杀人犯、强奸犯或绑架犯。绝不可能。我会接受DNA测试、测谎仪测试什么的来证明我的清白。我希望他们真的能抓住干这事的人，因为他们确实需要被关起来，但我知道我跟这事没关系，也什么都不知道。”被捕的第三个人是40岁的安吉拉·史密斯，科里纳的前室友。因为她在科里纳被强奸和谋杀时在场，却从未试图干预，她被指控犯有强奸、绑架和谋杀共谋罪。杰弗里·博伊德当时已经在因贩毒和篡改证据而服刑。第二天他被控强奸、绑架和谋杀。由于吉米·斯普林格已于1988年受审并被判无罪释放，他不能再次被指控杀害科里纳。相反，他被控犯有强奸、绑架和鸡奸共谋罪。
Corina's family were aware that arrests were imminent. The apprehending of Fields, Cramer, and Smith coincided with Patricia Mullins' birthday, but she had passed away one month prior. The Mullins were devastated to learn that the man they'd believed was helping to find their daughter's killer was actually the culprit. During the initial investigation, Fields visited the family home and sat at the kitchen table, offering comfort and commiserations. Once, he even took Claude Mullin out to look for clues together. Still, they were also relieved that arrests had finally been made. Claude told the Messenger Inquirer, We waited a lot of years. My wife passed away five weeks ago. That's what hurts. It was five weeks too early. I wish she could have waited a bit longer. Corina's daughter Stephanie, who was just a toddler when her mother died, was now 21 years old. She had just learned that she was pregnant when the news of the arrests broke.
科里纳的家人意识到逮捕行动即将来临。逮捕菲尔兹、克莱默和史密斯的行动恰逢帕特里夏·穆林斯的生日，但她已经在一个月前去世了。穆林斯一家得知他们原本以为在帮助寻找女儿凶手的人竟然是罪魁祸首时，感到极其痛心。在最初的调查期间，菲尔兹曾拜访过这个家庭，坐在厨房桌旁，提供安慰和哀悼。有一次，他甚至带克劳德·穆林一起去寻找线索。尽管如此，他们也为终于实施了逮捕感到一丝宽慰。克劳德告诉《信使问询报》：“我们等了很多年。我妻子在五 weeks 前去世了。这就是让人心痛的地方。早了整整五周。我真希望她能再多等一会儿。”科里纳的女儿斯蒂芬妮在母亲去世时还是个蹒跚学步的幼儿，现在已经21岁了。逮捕消息传出时，她刚刚得知自己怀孕了。
Corina's sister, Heather, told the Messenger Inquirer how difficult Stephanie's childhood had been, stating, It's bad enough to grow up without knowing your parents, but to get to know your parents in this way, it distorts the person she knows that her mom was. Watching her grow up and having to hear all these things about her mother, that was one of the worst things. The following month, a grand jury indicted all defendants on the charges that had been laid. The trial was initially slated to commence in November 2007, but was postponed so it could be moved to a court in another part of the state. Corina's murder and the individuals charged for it were so notorious in Muhlenberg County that there were fears the defendants wouldn't receive a fair trial there. Before the case finally began, the three charges against Angela Smith were dropped in exchange for testifying against Fields, Boyd and Cramer. She would instead face a single count of perjury for the false testimony she gave at Jimmy Springer's trial in 1988. She would be tried solo.
科里纳的姐姐海瑟对《信使问询报》讲述了斯蒂芬妮的童年有多么艰难，她表示：“在不了解父母的情况下长大已经够糟糕了，但以这种方式了解父母，会扭曲她所知道的妈妈的形象。看着她长大，不得不听到所有关于她母亲的这些事情，这是最糟糕的事情之一。”次月，大陪审团对所有被告提出了上述指控。审判最初定于2007年11月开始，但为了移交该州另一个地区的法院审理而延期。科里纳的谋杀案以及被起诉的个人在穆伦伯格县太出名了，以至于人们担心被告在那里无法获得公正的审判。在案件正式开审前，针对安吉拉·史密斯的三个指控被撤销，作为交换，她将出庭作证指控菲尔兹、博伊德和克莱默。她将仅面临一项伪证罪指控，因为她在1988年吉米·斯普林格的审判中作了虚假证词。她将单独受审。
Springer would also face courts separate from the others. On April 21, 2009, Billy Fields, Jimmy Cramer and Jeffrey Boyd all filed into court, handcuffed and dressed in orange prison jumpsuits. Now bespectacled and balding with a white ring of hair, Fields struck a very different figure than the imposing lawman he'd been back in the late 80s. Eyewitness Sarah took the stand and told the court about what she and Corina endured at the hands of the defendants more than 20 years earlier. The defendants' attorneys subjected her to a fierce cross-examination. They demanded to know why she hadn't spoken up earlier, especially when her own family members became involved with Jimmy Cramer. One cast doubt on her recollections by suggesting that if she really witnessed Corina's murder, then those responsible wouldn't have let her live to tell the tale. He theorized Sarah cobbled her story together from town gossip, but Sarah stood firm. Angela Smith had turned state's witness for the prosecution and explained how she'd lied during the original murder trial.
斯普林格也将与其他被告分开接受法院审判。2009年4月21日，比利·菲尔兹、吉米·克莱默和杰弗里·博伊德戴着手铐，穿着橙色囚服鱼贯进入法庭。如今戴着眼镜、秃顶并带着一圈白发的菲尔兹，与他在80年代末那个威风凛凛的执法人员形象大不相同。目击证人莎拉走上证人席，向法庭讲述了她和科里纳在20多年前遭受被告虐待的经历。被告的律师对她进行了严厉的盘问。他们质问她为什么不早点说出来，尤其是当她自己的家属与吉米·克莱默产生联系的时候。其中一人对她的记忆提出质疑，暗示如果她真的目击了科里纳的谋杀，幕后黑手绝不会让她活下来讲述真相。他推测莎拉是由城镇八卦拼凑出她的故事的，但莎拉立场坚定。安吉拉·史密斯已成为控方的州方证人，并解释了她在最初谋杀审判中是如何撒谎的。
Angela confirmed that she and Corina had gone out to a bar with Jeffrey Boyd on the night in question, prior to heading back to their apartment and the assault on Corina beginning. Billy Fields took the stand to testify in his own defense. He'd only worked two or three murder cases in his entire policing career, but still claimed his memory of the Corina Mullen case was vague. He detailed how he scoured Corina's bedroom for evidence and collected her hair for testing, though he couldn't recall finding any men's jeans or underwear in the room. Fields was shown crime scene photos of these items at the scene, with his legs visible in the background. He insisted he only vaguely knew Corina through her community service work. He was never involved with her and certainly hadn't been to her home. Eye witnesses who saw Fields' police cruiser parked outside Corina's residence multiple times gave evidence contradicting his claims. None of the other defendants testified. A former inmate who'd been incarcerated alongside Jimmy Cramer while he was awaiting trial gave evidence that Cramer showed him photos of Corina.
安吉拉证实，在事发当晚，她和科里纳曾与杰弗里·博伊德一起去酒吧，之后才返回公寓，随后对科里纳的袭击便开始了。比利·菲尔兹出庭为自己辩护。在他的整个警察生涯中，他只参与过两起或三起谋杀案的调查，但他仍坚称自己对科里纳·穆林斯案的记忆很模糊。他详细描述了他是如何在科里纳的卧室里搜寻证据并收集她的头发进行检测的，尽管他不记得在房间里找到过任何男士牛仔裤或内衣。法庭向菲尔兹展示了案发现场这些物品的照片，背景中隐约可见他的双腿。他坚称自己只是通过社区服务工作对科里纳略有了解。他从未与她有过染，更没有去过她家。看到菲尔兹的警车多次停在科里纳住所外面的目击证人提供了反驳他言论的证据。其他被告均未出庭作证。一名曾在吉米·克莱默候审期间与他同监的囚犯提供证据称，克莱默曾向他展示科里纳的照片。
Cramer obtained the photographs during the discovery phase of the trial, and today depicted her naked corpse in the car boot as well as during her autopsy. Cramer seemed proud of the images and bragged to his fellow inmate, look what we'd done to her. After a day's deliberation, the jury found the three defendants guilty on all counts. Jimmy Cramer received three 20-year sentences to be served consecutively for a total of 60 years. Billy Fields and Jeffrey Boyd were sentenced to life in prison with no possibility of parole. Corina's daughter Stephanie shared her relief as well as her sorrow, saying, We never thought this day would come. I didn't have a normal life because of them. My life was watching the two people I cared most about, my grandparents, cry every day.
克莱默是在审判的证据开示阶段获得这些照片的，如今这些照片描绘了车后备箱以及尸检过程中她赤裸的尸体。克莱默似乎对这些照片感到自豪，并在狱友面前吹嘘：“看看我们对她做了什么。”经过一天的审议，陪审团裁定三名被告所有罪名成立。吉米·克莱默被判处三项20年徒刑，合并执行，共计60年。比利·菲尔兹和杰弗里·博伊德被判处无期徒刑，不得假释。科里纳的女儿斯蒂芬妮分享了她的释然与悲伤，她说：“我们从没想过这一天会到来。因为他们，我没有过上正常的生活。我的一生都在看着我最在乎的两个人——我的祖父母——每天哭泣。”
In 2011, Fields, Boyd and Cramer all appealed their convictions but were denied. The details of what happened to Corina's boyfriend Jimmy Springer are unclear. Although he was to be tried separate for complicity to rape and kidnapping, case file was unable to find any record of relevant court cases. Springer has since served sentences for drug-related charges and was incarcerated for trafficking methamphetamine in 2020. Angela Smith pleaded guilty to perjury and was given a five-year suspended sentence. In the years since Corina was murdered, those who knew and loved her have endeavored to keep her memory alive. They remember Corina by her nickname Renny, her long, wavy, dark blonde hair, blue eyes and wide smile. Happy and strong-willed, she loved unicorns, teddy bears and the 1984 film Footloose.
2011年，菲尔兹、博伊德和克莱默都对他们的定罪提出上诉，但被驳回。科里纳的男友吉米·斯普林格的遭遇尚不清楚。尽管他将因强奸和绑架共谋罪被单独审判，但案卷中找不到任何相关法庭案件的记录。此后，斯普林格因涉毒罪名服刑，并于2020年因贩运甲基安非他命再次入狱。安吉拉·史密斯对伪证罪认罪，被判处五年缓刑。在科里纳被谋杀后的几年里，那些认识并爱她的人一直致力于让她的记忆永存。他们通过科里纳的昵称雷尼（Renny）、她长而波浪形的深金发、蓝眼睛和灿烂的微笑来记住她。她开朗而意志坚强，喜欢独角兽、泰迪熊和1984年的电影《浑身是劲》。
If she were alive today, Corina would now be a grandmother. At the time of his daughter's murder trial, Claude Mullen stated, We'll stick with it until it's done, no matter how long it takes. That's what I told them 20 years ago. I mean it then, and I mean it now. In the years following the guilty verdict, Claude Mullen found it easier to visit Corina's gravesite knowing justice had finally been served. He was initially heartbroken that his wife Patricia wasn't there to see it, remarking, I wish she were here. She probably wouldn't have believed it after all this hard work. Patricia was buried alongside her daughter in the open, grassy fields of Sunnyside Cemetery just outside of Central City.
如果她今天还活着，科里纳现在已经是一个祖母了。在女儿的谋杀案审判期间，克劳德·穆林表示：“不管花多长时间，直到事情水落石出，我们都会坚持到底。20年我对他们就是这么说的。那时候是，现在也是。”在有罪判决下达后的几年里，克劳德·穆林发现，知道正义最终得以伸张后，去科里纳的墓地祭扫变得更容易了。他最初为妻子帕特里夏没能看到这一幕而心碎，他评论道：“我希望她在这里。经历了这么多辛苦之后，她可能都不敢相信。”帕特里夏被安葬在中心城区郊外阳光山墓地开阔的草地上，紧挨着她的女儿。
In 2011, Claude was laid to rest alongside his wife and daughter. He would remain forever close to Corina, just as he had been in life. Corina had loved her family, especially her father. On special occasions, Corina would give her father a single red rose, and he would give her one in return. Corina's sister Heather, quote, The biggest thing I remember was that Corina had the brightest personality of any person we'll ever meet. She had a lot of energy, she loved to laugh, and she loved to be around her family. It was the best thing about her. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
2011年，克劳德被安葬在妻子和女儿身旁。他将永远陪伴在科里纳身边，正如他在生前所做的那样。科里纳一直深爱着她的家人，尤其是她的父亲。在特殊的日子里，科里纳会送给父亲一朵红玫瑰，而他也会回赠她一朵。科里纳的姐姐海瑟说：“我记得最深刻的是，科里纳是我们见过的所有人中最阳光开朗的性格。她充满活力，喜欢大笑，喜欢和家人在一起。这是她身上最好的特质。”这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。